Life is Beautiful puts the spotlight on
major acts and up and coming bands on
the rising star stage seikos is one of
those Rising bands and they join us now
we have David who is the lead singer and
Josh who is the drummer with us and the
rest of the guys here as well thanks for
joining us today thank you for having us
here okay let's start with the name
seikos what does the name game yeah so
seco's in Spanish means dry uh we are
all of Latin American uh descendants so
we wanted to choose a name that best
fits the band's personality how did you
guys all come together uh so um Jose and
Enrique got together during the pandemic
in 2020 they started you know playing
music together where they then recruited
me to play drums and I have a previous
relationship with Enrique so I was the
third member to joining the band and
then we reached out through social media
for Sergio and David and those there's a
connection through social media yeah
yeah I love it Vegas guys you know how
big Life is Beautiful is I mean this is
the Festival of all festivals how does
it feel to be playing life is beautiful
it's the best opportunity that we could
ever dream of this is this is so great
we're really excited for this
opportunity it's it's we're talking
earlier about Imagine Dragons Who
literally got their start by winning a
band battle for and then they played by
to Las Vegas for Mix 94.1 and now
they're playing the legion Stadium you
guys are on the same path as Imagine
Dragons right now oh yeah well thank you
who's so what are your Musical musical
influences we all have different
influences but you know we all come
together and have a a good amount of uh
similar bands but to name a few we have
MGMT that would be one of them we have
Interpol and Friends Ferdinand as some
of our biggest influences if you could
play with anyone alongside anyone who
would it be
um David well I would say it would be
with arctic monkeys and uh we are
playing
as Arctic Monkeys uh The Strokes
Interpol many bands that we would play
uh with so you're focused on Life is
Beautiful Friday night 7 30 is when you
guys are playing that's a prime time to
be playing too people will be amped up
to see you guys play on Friday night
what's next what's after that so we have
a couple of releases that we're gonna
come out with uh next week we have a new
song titled Moon okay that's gonna come
out right before life is beautiful so
everyone just check that out it's going
to be available on all streaming
platforms and we are also working on a
new EP which is a five song EP that we
plan to release throughout the remainder
of the year I mean how would you how do
you describe the sound that you guys put
out uh this is uh you know it's an indie
rock sound alternative rock I would say
it's it's dreamy you know that's what it
is it's dreamy we we feel like We're
Dreaming when we're making the music we
feel like We're Dreaming when we're
playing the music uh it's definitely
dreaming okay last question here is your
play in life is beautiful Hometown guys
you have your family and friends is
there anything you want to say to them
right there on the camera your family's
watching your parents are watching
Everyone's Watching what do you want to
say to them we want to say we we love
you thank you guys for supporting us we
wouldn't have be we wouldn't be here
right now if it weren't for your support
and uh just rock on continue uh
supporting saccos and let's let's do it
I love it when you guys sell out a
legion Stadium don't forget us right
thank you all right I'm seriously
awesome you guys I appreciate it have
fun and life is beautiful it's just
gonna be so good thank you guys Friday
night 7 30 at life is beautiful so
coming up here Elvis